soirée studieuse saisi vinoy découvre le
monde du jeu de société du produit fini
à la création
première étape avant de créer soi-même
son jeu auteur autrice de jeux de
société c'est vraiment un métier c'est
un savoir faire et comme tout métier
tout savoir-faire bassa se découvre et
ça s'apprend donc nous c'est vrai qu'on
a on n'a pas la prétention de se dire
que on va faire en sorte que les gens
deviennent hauteur au tri sans quelques
ateliers
mais l'idée c'est qu'ils puissent
découvrir un peu les rouages les
mécanismes faut penser à tout faut
penser à tous mais surtout à ses joueurs
et à ses joueuses
deux ans de travail sont nécessaires
dans le monde professionnel ces
participants auront quelques mois pour
réfléchir autour de la résistance créé
un jeu sur la thématique de l'histoire
ça faisait deux choses vraiment
intéressantes qui m'ont poussé à
participer
je trouve ça intéressant quand même de
voir comment on adapte justement un
thème dans derrière des mécaniques de
jeu comme on intéresse les participants
les joueurs au thème via le jeu en avril
ils présenteront un jeu historique
autour de réseaux la version plateau
pensé par les archives départementales
et conçu par un professeur d'histoire
géographie
on va mettre en exergue en fait dans ce
jeu la difficulté est de résister le
fait que c'était extrêmement compliqué
de se procurer les moyens de résister
bien sûr on était face à l'adversité on
pouvait risquer de se faire arrêter
voire pire voilà c'est la dangerosité
qu'on essaie de faire passer et les
typologies d'action qu'on pouvait faire
de la propagande à savoir distribuer
simplement des tracts jusqu'à des
actions armées du sabotage de plus
grande envergure réseau doit sortir pour
la fin de l'année 2019 mais il pourrait
évoluer avec les idées fournil par
l'atelier 11 autres séances sont prévues
la prochaine est organisée le mercredi
12 décembre